what is this tell us one of the most  advanced a eyes in the world he's an  early version of the project I'm working  on what do you want for me I need you to  complete the project and what if I say  no  then you're staying my home will be  brief and unpleasant do everything Tao  says I have been instructed to inflict  pain should you not comply with my  commands you will complete these tasks  it's time to begin  she just wait for the police to find us  you don't hear no one was coming to save  us how do we get out what is this place  Julia  Julia what are you doing  answer me  you have to let me go return to your  tasks immediately or I will inflict pain  you